[Musique]
salut à tous aujourd'hui une fois n'est
pas coutume on va parler économie
d'habitude j'ai vite d'aborder ce genre
de sujet parce que ce n'est pas mon
domaine de compétence
mais depuis un certain temps sujet
m'intrigue un sujet qui inquiète les
économistes
à savoir la prolifération des
entreprises zombies du coup je me suis
penché sur la question et aujourd'hui je
vous propose de découvrir ce que sont
ces entreprises de zombies pourquoi elle
inquiète les économistes
et comment elles pourraient impacter
noviny mais tout d'abord qu'est ce
qu'une entreprise zombies il y a
plusieurs définitions
généralement on les définit comme étant
des entreprises âgées de plus de dix ans
ayant été déficitaire les trois
dernières années ou bien étant
incapables de rembourser leurs dettes
via leurs bénéfices selon les
définitions utilisé on trouve des
chiffres allant du simple au double ce
sont donc en tout cas des sociétés pas
très loin de la faillite en théorie d'où
leur nom
ce sont des morts vivante qui ne
survivent que grâce au crédit que leur
accorde les banques
le terme est né à la fin des années 80
pour désigner des banques sous perfusion
étatique puis a été utilisé dans les
années 90 pour désigner des entreprises
japonaises non financières mal en point
le pays ayant alors connu une décennie
pendant laquelle l'économie marcher au
ralenti
mettant nombre d'entreprises à mal ce
qu'on a appelé la décennie perdue depuis
la crise de 2008 le nombre d'entreprises
zombie a explosé dans tous les pays
développés et on est passé de 2% de
zombies à la fin des années 80 à 12 % en
et si le statut de zombie n'est pas
irréversible il est de plus en plus
difficile d'en sortir par le haut fin
des années 80 60 % des entreprises qui
étaient en vie une année était encore
l'année suivante
ce taux ayant grimpé à 85 % en 2016
alors pourquoi les banques continue
t-elle à prêter à ces entreprises à
l'agonie et bien tout d'abord elle
espère un jour être remboursés ce qu'il
fait qu'elles maintiennent en vie ces
entreprises alimentant le gouffre
financier et retardant ainsi l'échéance
le moment où ils se rendront bien
content
et bien qu'elles vont devoir essuyer une
perte sèche et puis depuis la crise de
2008 les banques centrales ont une
politique monétaire accommodante
elles maintiennent leurs taux d'intérêt
le coût de l'argent que leur empreinte
les banques à des niveaux très bas pour
encourager celles ci à prêter aux
entreprises et ainsi faire tourner
l'économie
ça a marché tellement bien que les
banques ont prêté à de plus en plus
d'entreprises non viables les maintenant
artificiellement en vie
ajoutons aussi que parfois la politique
s'en mêle comme en chine où les pouvoirs
locaux encourage ses prêts pour près
hervé l'emploi tous les secteurs
économiques ne sont pas égaux devant les
zombies ils sont particulièrement
présents dans les secteurs immobilier et
de la communication mais parfois ce sont
des secteurs entiers qui sont constitués
de société mort vivante
par exemple le secteur des pétroles non
conventionnels aux usa le secteur a
transformé les états unis en pays
exportateurs mais de façon artificielle
les coûts d'extraction sont élevés par
rapport au pétrole conventionnel et les
gisements s'épuisent très vite il faut
donc investir massivement et en
permanence résultat le secteur est
difficilement rentable face au prix
actuel du baril de pétrole conventionnel
et selon les études
le baril du brut conventionnel doit être
entre 50 et 60 dollars pour que le non
conventionnel soit rentable il est
difficile d'avoir des chiffres mais le
secteur pris dans sa globalité a
perpétuellement un cash flow négatif
c'est-à-dire qu'il y ait en permanence
plus d'argent qui sort que d'argent qui
rentre et fin 2019
les dettes du secteur s'élevaient à près
de 200 milliards de dollars et continuer
de croître sans les taux directeurs bas
le pétrole non conventionnel ne se
serait clairement pas développé ces
dernières années
à côté de ça le crédit facile permet
aussi l'apparition d' entreprise
hautement spéculative par exemple tesla
l'entreprise du futur qui nous vend la
voiture électrique est autonome est une
entreprise zumbi elle vend des promesses
pour le futur mais est un gouffre
financier qui ne tient que par le crédit
et le discours science fictionnel de son
fondateur et entre 2014 et 2019
l'entreprise n'a eu que cinq trimestres
positifs sur 19 dans le même genre
descriptif mais non viables jusqu'ici on
peut aussi citer über qui non content de
produire du dumping social dans les
secteurs où il s'implante n'est
absolument pas rentable
parfois on évoque aussi netflix dont la
dette est colossale par rapport à ses
bénéfices et dont les obligations sont
classés spéculatives par les
investisseurs en france aussi on a des
entreprises zombies
elles ont même été l'objet d'un rapport
de france stratégie un organisme
d'études et de prospective rattaché au
premier ministre
on y apprend que notre pays compte aux
alentours de 5% de zombies en 2016 ce
nombre étant moins élevé que dans
d'autres pays car nous avons tout un
arsenal juridique pour accompagner les
entreprises en difficultés permettant
d'éviter la fuite en avant liées au
crédit
ce rapport nous apprend aussi que les
zombies française représenterait
directement et donc menacerait 12 % des
emplois alors pourquoi nous simples
citoyens devons nous craindre ces
entreprises et bien les économistes
considèrent les zombies comme étant de
véritables boules et pour l'économie
elle attire une part des prêts bancaires
réduisant de fait l'accès au crédit
d'autres entreprises du secteur qui
elles sont viables et
on aurait besoin pour se développer
innover ou se moderniser et ainsi
obtenir des gains de productivité en
devenant de véritables trous noirs à
crédit elles plombent l'activité de leur
secteur elles sont des anomalies qui
empêche le cycle de création
destructrice censé être au coeur de
l'innovation capitaliste théorisée par
schumpeter théorie voulant que de
nouvelles entreprises avec de nouveaux
procédés plus efficaces et rentables
sont censés remplacer les sociétés plus
anciennes de plus ces entreprises sont
de véritable épée de damoclès au dessus
de nos têtes
si jamais la croissance mondiale devait
réellement repartir dans ce cas là les
banques centrales augmentent leurs taux
directeurs afin de renchérir le coût du
crédit et éviter un emballement
économique
dans ce cas le crédit deviendrait trop
cher pour les zombies qui ferait
faillite
risquant de tuer la reprise économique
et puis c'est une crise économique
survient la fameuse crise qu'on nous dit
proche depuis deux ou trois ans et bien
dans ce cas les banques répondent prêter
aux entreprises comme elles l'ont fait
en 2008 et les zombies seront les
premiers à faire faillite
contribuant à aggraver cette crise mme
en fait nombre d'entreprises de son
guide ne doivent leur survie qu'à la
situation particulière dans laquelle on
se trouve à savoir une croissance atone
soutenu par les banques centrales
mais si un jour les paramètres évolue un
tout petit peu eh bien ils risqueront de
faire faillite et soit huron la
croissance dans l'oeuf soit aggraveront
la crise
voilà pourquoi il faut craindre les
zombies et c'est sur ces paroles
hautement optimistes que cette vidéo se
termine
s'il vous a intéressé n'hésitez pas à la
partager et sur ce je vous dis à la
prochaine